A FEW MINUTES AGO, PRESIDENT
TRUMP TWEETED HIS THANKS TO THE
SECRET SERVICE FOR A JOB WELL
DONE.
A FORMER CAMPAIGN AIDE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PLEADING
GUILTY TO CONSPIRACY AND TAX
CHARGES BROUGHT BY RUSSIA'S
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
THIS COMES AS THE FORMER TRUMP
CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN TAKES ANOTHER
LEGAL HIT.
HERE TO STRAIGHTEN IT ALL OUT,
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE AT THE D.C.
DISTRICT COURT WITH DETAILS.
GOOD EVENING.
>> THANK YOU, BRET.
I WAS INSIDE THE COURTROOM WHEN
RICK GATES PLED GUILTY TO TWO
FELONIES.
HE SEEMED REMARKABLY CALM
THROUGHOUT UNTIL THE FINAL
MINUTES WHEN HE ENTERED THE
GUILTY PLEA AND SEALED HIS FATE
WITH A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
GATES PLED GUILTY TO CONSPIRACY
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES WHICH
IS A BASKET OF CHARGES INCLUDING
BANK AND TAX FRAUD, HIDING
INCOME FROM THE I.R.S. AND
FAILING TO REGISTER FOR WORK ON
BEHALF OF A PRO RUSSIAN PARTY IN
THE UKRAINE.
THE OFFENSES SPAN 2006 TO 2014
BUT DID NOT OVERLAP WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
ON THE SECOND COUNT, MAKING A
FALSE STATEMENT TO THE F.B.I.,
GATES TOLD INVESTIGATORS THAT A
MARCH 2013 MEETING BETWEEN A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND HIS BOSS,
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN
PAUL MANAFORT DID NOT INCLUDE
THE TOPIC OF THE UKRAINE WHEN
GATES DIDN'T KNOW BECAUSE HE
WASN'T THERE.
MANAFORT WHO WAS HIT WITH MORE
CHARGES TODAY RELATED TO HIS
LOBBYING ON BEHALF OF UKRAINE
SAID IN A STATEMENT "I HOPED AND
EXPECTED MY BUSINESS COLLEAGUE
WOULD HAVE THE STRENGTH TO
CONTINUE OUR BOUT TO PROVE OUR
INNOCENCE.
THIS HAS NOT ALTERED MY
COMMITMENT TO DEFEND MYSELF
AGAINST THE UNTRUE PILED UP
CHARGES CONTAINED IN THE
INDICTMENTS AGAINST ME."
AS HE LEFT COURT TODAY, GATES
DID NOT ANSWER REPORTERS'
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER HE WILL
TESTIFY AGAINST MANAFORT.
COURT RECORDS SHOW THERE'S A
STANDARD COOPERATION AGREEMENT
BUT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE GATES IS
ALREADY HELPING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
GATES NOW BECOMES THE FIFTH
PERSON TO PLEAD GUILTY IN THE
WIDE RANGING RUSSIAN PROBE AND
HE'S FACING SEVERAL YEARS IN
FEDERAL JAIL AS WELL AS UP TO
$200,000 IN FINES BUT ALL OF